Yeah.
But why can't they spinning back fist boxing?
I don't know.
Should I be able to Paris,
they are very purist,
but I see where they're coming from in a certain way.
Like when boxers talk shit about MMA and striking in MMA,
I see where they're coming from the wrong because your shit won't work.
Like come try that shit.
You're going to get taken down stupid.
Like this is the whole reason why they do it a different way.
But I actually do believe that a boxer with incredible footwork and a jab,
a great job could survive and win in an MMA fight is as long as he doesn't fight
a long guy with good kicks,
like a Jon Jones.
Jon Jones just kicked the shit out of you from a distance and you're not even
going to get close to him.
And then by the time you've eaten all those leg kicks,
you're not moving so good.
Yeah.
And the variable hold you and smash your face.
And I agree.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I think,
I think footwork is key.
Do you remember when Vince Foster,
when he was a shit,
not quite world class anymore.
He'd lost the title and this is what worries me because I don't remember shit.
You don't remember shit?
Well,
he fought Masato,
but when Masato was the king of k one over Japan,
Masato the sexiest Japanese man I've ever seen.
A pretty sexy.
Yeah.
He's super lazy.
Sexy isn't sexy.
Yama.
I don't know.
Sexy Yama is what you don't know.
Sexy is sexy.
I haven't fought in the UFC several times.
Fought in pride.
Yeah.
That's a great name though.
A gorgeous,
gorgeous man.
I feel like that should be a super Sushi roll.
There is.
There's sexy Yama Asados way better looking.
Yeah.
You say that you're not succeeding was presence.
Look at that.
I like the way it glows.
Yeah.
Look at them,
man.
It's beautiful.
Like those pecs.
Yeah.
He's got that cross dangling.
Super Low.
What's going on with that?
You look that cro,
it's almost like a belly button ring or some shit.
That's a deal breaker,
right?
A dude with a belly button ring.
How about that?
A Guy,
a gorgeous guy with a belly button ring.
And when he's Freaky,
is that what it means?
He vain or gay as fuck.
More likely.
That's something men just never rubbing.
It means he's freaky or he takes too many selfies.
Yeah,
it definitely does.
She eat.
So,
yeah.
Is that something any man has ever bravely tried to rock my note guys do nipple
rings,
like a real freaky dude.
We'll doing it once you've seen it.
A belly button ring a male.
So one time I saw a pierced.
Who's that?
Oh there it is.
Beautiful.
I thought you were showing me a belly button ring.
There's better pictures of him.
He's very handsome and still is and you know,
and,
and still,
you know,
is very active and all sorts of promotions and stuff.
Japan,
when he fought,
um,
no,
when he was going to fight Petrosian and portraiture and was killing sour,
what happened?
It was supposed to be his like,
uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
And so he's watching Petrosian just,
I think it was sour,
destroy any sour and uh,
he's just like,
fuck was like a pull up Masako versus,
um,
Vince Philips because what was interesting about this,
it was a,
it was like,
do you remember when I'm Shannon the cannon,
um,
decided to fight in k one and he fought,
uh,
Tom Erickson and a kickboxing match.
No,
you don't remember,
but that was a similar thing,
but Tom Erickson was not,
you know,
Tom Erickson was a wrestler who was an MMA fighter and a Shannon Briggs eight,
a couple of leg kicks and he was talking about it on the podcast like that.
He was trying to play it off.
It was like,
God damn,
that shit hurt.
But,
uh,
he wound up Kaylin,
Tom Erickson,
but Tom Erickson at the time was not nearly the kind of Stryker that Vince
Phillips was when Vince Phillips Swap Masato.
Vince Phillips had beaten worldclass fighters,
I think.
Who did he beat?
He beat some fucking high level worldclass boxers.
And then,
you know,
we got like 36 37 38 and then took this fight was 37 at the time.
So he fought Vince Phillips.
But it was so weird seeing Vince Phillips walk out there barefoot.
I mean they should have let him wear boxing shoes cause he's not thrown into
kicks.
Yeah.
And Masato just get gimme some fit.
Beautiful Man.
Perfect bone structure.
He's ridiculous.
Perfect hair to English.
And Vince Phillips was like,
what the fuck did I sign up for?
Yeah,
that feeling that they have when they're about to get leg kicked.
So right away opens up inside and just moves away from the punches.
Sets goes up high.
It goes up high punched times,
kicking into the arms and that goes across the leg.
See that's a,
that's a weird one right there across the thigh.
Not shot anywhere.
Throw that one.
But this was,
this is at the time,
like one of the first times that a,
a real worldclass boxer had attempted a kickboxing fight.
And that's um,
I love that he did this.
Friends both.
I did that too.
Do you remember friends?
Both of who was a heavyweight contender and boxing in the eighties and nineties
to watching fights.
If you talked to my wife and ask her what she told me about 10 minutes ago,
I will not remember what the fuck she said.
A lot of shit that I don't remember.
But I have like storage units in my brain and stuff like,
oh that's interesting.
What happened there?
This happened.
Oh,
why did that happen?
Why did this go wrong?
Oh,
okay.
Pull up a Georgia Petrosian versus um,
uh,
Andy Sour as a u e r does it know how's that high spot?
Oh,
here's friends both though.
Yeah,
so friends,
both.
Uh,
this is France.
Both of fat as fuck too.
He had like,
he had hit the wall,
he was the white buffalo.
He's a South African heavyweight,
but he uh,
he actually learned how to kick a little bit and he was not just boxing guys,
but his,
his hands were just way better than most boxers are.
Most kickboxers rather cause he was at one point in time,
a real heavyweight contender.
This is not a good example.
This is 2015 holy shit,
dude,
that this is 2000 this guy was a fucking contender in the 90s he's already hurt.
Oh yeah.
This is had a thrown a knee.